- Thank you for coming to my city.
- I know!
I'm in your city!
- So nice of you.
- I was gonna, thank you for showing up.
I was really gonna be sad if
I didn't get you on my show,
and I was actually in New York.
- Yeah, well, I would never
have done that to you.
- I was like, "I would be really sad."
I love you so much.
- Have to sit on the couch.
- Sit comfortably?
Here's the best part
that people don't know.
It's such a beautiful view.
It is legit like you're
sitting in a sauna right now.
- It's 1,000 degrees right
now in New York City.
- Imagine, like, if you were wearing Spanx
which I'm totally not.
- No.
- But if you were, how
incredibly hot it would be!
- No, and from--
- Yeah.
- a male perspective, if I was
wearing Manx, which I'm not,
I could also tell you that
certain heat, it rides up.